there's no excuse for not talking to the
world it just doesn't have to be your
thoughts and words every time you should
be putting up 7 to 25 pieces of content
a day and let me explain how Don't Go
Fancy document versus create it's a big
shift when I say 7 to 25 you say my God
how do I produce 7 to 25 meaningful
things that will have me respected
versus document I still can't believe
how many people that live in New York
don't use New York people if I were you
and I had an hour right now go in the
park right now like stand
outside the garden right there and be
like what do you think about the Nick's
upcoming season interview four people
one person gets into a thoughtful
conversation he was the former ball boy
in 1957 it's a nice story and boom
people aren't starting so you can't
create distribute there's no excuse for
not talking to the world it just doesn't
have to be your thoughts and words every
time